Підйом о 4-й ранку: як заробляє на життя український студент у Німеччині
Навколо яких цінностей волонтерка вже три десятки років об'єднує німців заради допомоги Україні
Чому український піаніст-віртуоз створив недільну українську школу в Німеччині
Друзі, всім привіт! У ваших коментарях ви неодноразово пропонували розповісти про життя українців у Німеччині.
Аби якомога докладніше висвітлити цю тему-я покажу вам історії представників трьох поколінь.
Сьогодні я не дарма біля стін Боннського університету. Тут у мене запланована зустріч з нашим першим героєм.
Студент сільськогосподарського факультету Вадим Стоянз’являється вчасно, як і домовлялись, рівно об 11-й.
Одразу зізнається, чому в Німеччині особливо почав цінувати пунктуальність.
Якщо ти домовляєшся з німцем про зустріч і прийшов там хоча б на 5-10 хвилин пізніше - він сприйме це як за образу.
В Україні Вадим до 3 курсу навчався в Національному університеті біоресурсів і природокористування у Києві,
потім склав німецьку на рівень С1, мав високі бали з усіх предметів і 2019 року вступив на бакалаврат з агрономії до Боннського університету.
Подача матеріалу й інформації доступніша,ніж в Україні.
Також відмінність полягає в тому, що практичні заняття ведуть не професори, а студенти старших курсів.
Заснований у 1818 році Боннський університет відомий такими випускниками як філософ Фрідріх Ніцше та перший канцлер ФРН Конрад Аденауер.
Тут також деякий час навчалися композитор Людвіґ ван Бетховен та філософ-економіст Карл Маркс.
Коридорами, якими ходили ці постаті зараз мене проводить 22-річний уродженець села Кривачинці з Хмельницької області.
У Вадима вже є чіткий план своєї подальшої кар’єри агронома із конкретними сумами заробітку.
І вже як практикант помічником агронома можна отримати зарплатню.
До сплати податків-1500 євро. В подальшому планую працювати на роботі вже як головний агроном на фермерському господарстві.
Зарплатня там буде від 2500 євро і далі.
Зі своїх спостережень за два роки у Німеччині Вадим дійшов висновку,
що німці інколи дуже серйозно сприймають речі в тих ситуаціях, де цього можна було б уникнути.
У таких випадках він вважає, що німці могли б повчитися легкості й навіть самоіронії в українців.
Водночас землякам радить наступне.
Українцям варто повчитися у німців уваги до деталей, організованості, структурованості
у своїх справах,у своїй роботі,ну і взагалі,порядку в домі і на господарстві.
Саме навчання у Німеччині безкоштовне, а от для того, щоб я дізнався,як Вадим заробляє на проживання,
тепер він мені призначає зустріч.
Друзі 5-та ранку у Бонні. Давно мені ніхто не призначав зустрічі о цій порі.
Ну,що ж,подивимось,як заробляє на життя студент Боннського університету з України.
Вадим тягне візочок,в якому завантажені 160 газет.
Розношу газети. Ось тут, наприклад,"Генераль Анцайгер".
Зранку в період з чотирьох до шести або з п’яти до семи.
·О котрій прокидаєшся для цього?
Десь о четвертій або опів на четверту ранку.
За дві години треба встигнути рознести газети по поштових скриньках підписників у двох кварталах міста.
Завдяки цій роботі Вадим також дізнався, що більшість німців рано лягають спати та рано встають,і вже чекають на його газети.
О сьомій ранку студент повертається до гуртожитку.
Ну,все, робочий день закінчено, ну що поп’єм чаю?
Умивальник, шафа, ліжко, робочий стіл - все компактно розміщено на 20 квадратних метрах.
Туалет, душ і кухня загальні. В університетському гуртожитку для Вадима не вистачило місця, тож він орендує кімнату в комерційної фірми.
На газетах я заробляю у місяць 500 євро. Це вже з податками. Це вистачає в принципі на все,на кімнату 375 євро
й обов’язково потрібно мати страховку державну студентську,за яку я плачу 100 євро в місяць.
З побажаннями Вадиму успіхів у навчанні і професійному становленні вирушаю до наступної нашої героїні у містечко Раттінген, що поблизу Дюссельдорфа.
Віра Костюк Буш на своєму подвір’ї саме встановлює на флагштоці український прапор, який буревій зніс вночі, й поправляє американський.
Доля цієї етнічної українки тісно пов’язана з Німеччиною і Сполученими Штатами.
За чаєм чоловік пані Віри згадує,як вони познайомилися у Майнці 1970 року в студентському гуртожитку,
куди американка приїхала як стипендіатка програми імені Фулбрайта.
Віра прийшла як студентка, яка мала жити у моїй кімнаті після мене.
Я знав трохи українську, бо я з моїм батьком ще хлопчиком ходив на церковні богослужіння українською у церкві у Крефельді.
Потім був обід на День подяки і я отримав від Віри смачнючий шматок грудки американської індички. І вже майже 48 років ми в Німеччині разом.
Історія родини Віри Костюк Буш заслуговує на екранізацію.
Під час Другої світової війни її матір, яка народилася і жила у Рогатині, вивезли на примусові роботи до Німеччини.
Там вона працювала на меблевій фабриці.
Після війни працюючи в американській компанії у Франкфурті-на-Майні зустріла українця родомтеж з Івано-Франківщини.
У 1946 році вони побралися. У Франкфурті у них і народилася донька Віра.В середині 50-хродина емігрує до США,
де виховує своїх трьох дітей в українському та релігійному дусі. У 1970 році Віра Костюк Буш повертається до Німеччини,
виходить заміж за німця і вони як туристи вперше в житті їдуть до Української РСР.
То було 73 року. Цікаво було, бо то були радянські часи.Цілком інакше.
Як я в"Інтурист"купувала білети на оперу, то відразу якийсь пан коло нас сидів. І тоді я бачу-він за нами.
Ми до трамваю, він до трамваю. То так,як колись шпигуни, так було.
КолиУкраїнастала незалежною,пані Віра одразу розпочала свою благодійну діяльність, яку не полишає й досі.
У 90-х роках вона організувала 6 гуманітарних експедицій до України з Німеччини.
У кожній з них було доставлено 40 тонн вантажів.
Загальна сума витрачена на речі, необхідні для українських шкіл, сиріт та будинків для літніх людей сягалатоді мільйона німецьких марок.
Переглядаючи фото початку 90-х, пані Віра згадує,як тоді відкрила німців для себе як людей, які мають сильні благодійницькі та волонтерські традиції.
Німецький уряд та Федеральна агенція технічної допомоги надали вантажівки та оплатили роботу 10 рятувальників, які доставили допомогу до України.
Загалом Віра написала півсотні оголошень в газети і німці на кожну її гуманітарну експедицію в Україну жертвували серйозні суми.
Вміння німців гуртуватися заради допомоги іншим надихнуло Віру Костюк Буш на створення об’єднання"Pro Ukrainee.V.",
яке з 2003 року опікується рогатинською гімназією, де перед війною навчалася її мати.
Щобмали ті,хто потребують гарячий обід чи комп’ютери,
я дістала 28 лептопів чи ми стараємося тепер будувати молодечий центр.
Віра Костюк Буш з гордістю показує нагороду за свою благодійну діяльність від президента України Петра Порошенка.
Перегляд світлин її поїздок до України за останні три десятки років Незалежності-як ретроспектива того, як країна і люди змінилися за цей час
і нагадування про те, скільки ще роботи попереду для побудови успішної європейської держави.
Саме тут у місті Раттінген у музичній школіна мене чекає наступний герой цієї серії-уродженець Львова, піаніст-віртуоз Яромир Боженко.
Він живе в Ессені і спеціально їздить сюди давати уроки.Це клас, в якому піаніст кілька днів на тиждень займається зі своїми учнями.
Як каже наш директор з нашої школи, що кожний учень, який приходить до школи сюди - це є на одну молоду людину проблеми менше для поліцаїв
у майбутньому, бо хто займається музикою-той не буде ні грабувати, ні битися ніде.
За словами Яромира, загалом у Німеччині більше дітей,ніж в Україні,мають базові музичні знання. У цій школі місяць навчання на фортепіано коштує 48 євро.
Дитина має один 25-хвилинний урок на тиждень.
Однак в Україні більше саме дітей, які мають навички володіння інструментом вище середнього,через наявність
спеціалізованих музичних шкіл з більшою кількістю і тривалістю уроків.
Завдяки українській музичній освіті й талантуз 1992 року Яромир регулярно перемагав у міжнародних конкурсах піаністів і виступав з концертами по світу.
Завжди у своїх виступах робив акцент на композиторах української класичної музики і відкривав їх для закордонної аудиторії.
Ось на цьому концерті звучить соната Левка Ревуцького.
У 2001 році разом з дружиною, професійною скрипалькою Ольгою Глібович, Яромир вступив до університету мистецтв Фолькванг у місті Ессен.
Навчання й аспірантура тривали9років.
За цей час народилися двоє дітей і родина вирішила залишитися у Німеччині,
бо тут подружжя могло вести гідне життя, займаючись лише музикою. За два десятиліття у німецькому соціумі Яромир має такі спостереження.
Тобто якщо ми говоримо про німців у Мюнхені й німців у Штутгарті-вони цілком інші, ніж німці тут, у Рурському регіоні.
Але їх об’єднує одна, я вважаю, дуже позитивна якість-це дотримання законності.Того, чого в Україні бракує.
Водночас, за словами піаніста, бажання німців все зарегулювати до перфекціонізму інколи має навіть комічні наслідки.
Існує книжка на 600 сторінок, яка описує,як ти маєш вести свій город. Маєш город десь там окремо і є певний закон,
який розписує,до якої висоти мають право бути гномики, скільки має бути відсотків трави, скільки відсотків дерев, овочів і фруктів.
А на цих кадрах вже сам Яромир впорядковує розклад в українській недільній школі"Рідне слово"у Дюссельдорфі,
про яку мріяв багато років і яку завдяки підтримці українського консульства та однодумців таки вдалося відкрити у 2018 році.
Ти би мала дві мови, те, що ти ведеш із садочком завжди. А далі би Оксана мала малювання, так?
Діти з родин, де прагнуть зберегти українську мову і культуру мають в неділю уроки з 9 до 13 години.
Батьки привозять їх на заняття з різних куточків землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія. Учні поділені на чотири вікові групи.
Загалом навчається 45 дітей.Усіх вчителів Яромир знайшов в українській спільноті.
Вперше я познайомився з Яромиром вже тут, у Німеччині, це вже було понад 10 років тому.
Це сталося в греко-католицькій нашій церкві, у храмі. Так склався наш хор
у церкві і якось прийшла така думка після однієї з таких служб-у нас є гарний парафіяльний зал,
де ми всі збираємося-а що якби нам організувати таку школу.
В Україні я навчалася у педагогічному університеті у місті Тернопіль на факультеті іноземних мов.
І мені дуже важливо зберегти своє українське коріння і передати його своїй дочці.
І тому коли я почула, що організовується така чудова ініціатива-українська школа у місті Дюссельдорф,я залюбки до неї приєдналася.
Стараюся тут підтримати культуру, мову, історію, географію, щоб дітям це було відомо, щоб діти про це знали,щоб діти не переживали,
що вони тут знаходяться,і вони якісь свої чи не свої,і вони находять своїх друзів і однодумців.
Під патронатом школи тепер українська громада проводить різні заходи - от як це дитяче святкування Дня Незалежності України
уцеркві Христа Царя у Дюссельдорфі.
Німецьке законодавство дозволяє створювати неприбутковілагодійні організації, тож для посилення української громади,
можливості організації культурних і спортивних заходів та підтримки однойменної школи в Дюссельдорфі
та інших містах землі Північний Рейн-ВестфаліяЯромир ще організувавоб’єднання"Рідне Слово".
Друзі, ну я не можу не скористатися такою нагодою і не зіграти разом з піаністом-віртуозом Яромиром Боженко, поїхали!
Шановні глядачі відеоблогу"Відкривай Німеччину",
пишіть у ваших коментарях, що ще б ви хотіли знати про ФРН і побачите це в одній із наступних серій. Хай щастить!